good morning Hank it's Friday I woke up
last Sunday in Bruges Oh wonder what
happened the night before what starts
with a L and runs with mistake let's
have another beer
take got up anyway took a shower brushed
my teeth got dressed wait why aren't you
brushing your teeth because I left my
toothbrush in Amsterdam right so I
headed out into Bruges with a burning
need to disregard currency and acquire
one a toothbrush and two some of that
fancy Belgian chocolate I'd heard so
much about
fortunately Bruges has a lot of stores
unfortunately most of them are closed on
Sunday mornings and I was starting to
worry that I was going to have to do the
non-ideal pre-modern thing of brushing
one's teeth with one's finger went up
look chocolate the woman wrapped up my
chocolate for me in a fancy box as if I
was not going to eat it right away you
know hang that the ancient Belgians used
chocolate as a way of stating off bad
breath is a fact I just made up I found
a lot of places that didn't sell
toothbrushes like the French fry Museum
in a fancy shoe store in a book store
with John Green books in the concept
store which presumably only sells
concepts I wanted to buy utilitarianism
but it was closed I kept walking until
at last I found Sam and Co a Burt Winkle
Hank I know from my extensive knowledge
of Dutch that Winkle means store I could
only hope that Burt meant toothbrush and
it did it did occur to me that I paid
two euros for something that if you gave
me 100 years I could not build from
scratch I think I realized this is
stating the obvious but everything in
Bruges is really fracking old this is a
school and this is a dominoes parts of
Bruges is famous belfry date back to
1240 meaning that this building is four
hundred years older than the idea of
gravity I heard a lot of people call
Bruges quaint but while it did feel like
an open-air History Museum to me there's
nothing quaint about living amid history
grappling with the gifts and
insufficiencies of your ancestors to
live in Bruges is to be reminded every
day that there were people before you
were a person which of course also
reminds you that there will be people
after I think we owe both the dead and
the not yet living precisely the same
thing the daily awareness that human
life is ours only in trust it's worth
remembering that 700 years later we
don't remember the individuals who built
the belfry or dug the canals we don't
remember their political affiliations or
even their nationalistic identities we
remembered
as a collective just as we ourselves
will be remembered as a collective for
what we did and failed to do together
later I found myself in a park with
nerdfighters from all over Belgium
grateful to be part of a community that
builds friendships while trying to make
the world suck less
in short Hank I felt grateful to the
13th century but lucky to be alive in
2011 living in a world where with a
series of ones and zeros we can build
our own relationships and our own
monuments plus toothbrushes are crazy
cheap Hank I'll see you on Monday